This is Ben. He's a cocktail consultant
who helps restaurants and bars optimize
their drink menus to increase profits.
But his revenue is unstable. Sometimes
he has a great month and then other
times he sells nothing and sometimes
that goes down. I'm Alexi. I own
acquisition.com or portfolio of
companies that generate hundreds of
millions of dollars per year in revenue.
What I suspect Ben needs to work on is
optimizing his funnel, fixing his offer.
He's trying to sell a $30,000 thing to
strangers who've never even worked with
him before, which is pretty tough. And
then once that all that stuff's fixed,
spending more on his actual marketing.
So, the first thing I'm going to do is
dive deep into the business and then I'm
going to break down all the tactics that
he and you can use to scale your
business to your dreams. Hey, Alex. I'm
Ben. Hello. One of the co-founders of
Unfiltered Hospitality, where we help
hospitality operators build better
beverage programs. Tell me about the
business. So, we are bar and beverage
program development specialists. In
2024, we did 1.1 million in revenue,
123,000 in net profit, so about 11.3% in
uh net margins. We've been in business
for about 4 and 1/2 years, but we've
helped over 200 bars launch or elevate
their concepts. So, what's the goal?
What do you want to do? My goal, 3
million by the end of 2020. It's big
goals. Yeah. Triple this year. All
right. Yeah. Triple this year. Rock and
roll. So, how did you get started? Uh,
in 2008, I started my life in the world
as an investment banker. Okay. And so, I
hated it. Quit my job there. Over the
next 7 years, I worked in bars and
restaurants around the city. A few years
after that, I opened my first bar. It
was all going really well until 2020.
Okay. We all remember what happened
then. Uh it was just like this small
pandemic. It's over now, so we're good.
That's good. Yeah. Fortunately, I got
approached by a restaurant that was
still operational and they said, "We
need new cocktails." I said, "Great. I'm
very good at that." So, I tapped my
business partner, Ghee, and so we
started Unfiltered Hospitality. All
right. Yeah. So, who do you help? We
currently work with restaurants, hotels,
bars, country clubs, cruise ships,
nightclubs. If they have a bar, we help
them. How do you help them? We help them
by taking their bar programs from good
to great. Phase one, which we call
better cocktail consulting, takes 90
days. We design a cocktail menu for
them. We train their teams and then we
install an operating system to keep it
all running smoothly. Phase one is
better cocktail consulting. Phase two.
Phase two is what we call the program
performance retainer. Okay, so the point
of this is to maintain what we did with
Better Consulting and then continue
to develop the program and we do that by
having a weekly KPI call where we check
the scorecard to see how well your
metrics are doing. We also then provide
seasonal monthly seasonal cocktails. We
want to maintain the training and so we
have a quarterly training program where
we fly out there and we significant
train the team for two days. You don't
mind flying? That's good cuz I have an
idea for you. So, I have an inkling that
Ben needs to go up market. Restaurants
that make over a certain amount of
money, they're going to think about like
a business, not just like their passion
project. Passion project business owners
are kind of tough to deal with when you
come from a business perspective.
They're not willing to make like
sometimes really obvious, clear, good
business decisions for whatever limiting
belief they have. Okay, so that's how
you help them. Um, how do you make
money? Great. Our core offer, which is
what most people buy from us, is better
cocktail consulting. We charge 30,000
for that. And again, that's just the
development and implementation. And what
we love to do is upsell everybody or at
least have them initially buy the better
beverage program, which is what we call
better cocktail consulting plus multiple
program performance retainers. Okay.
What percentage of people go from the
core offer to the upsell? Less than less
than 20%. Ding, ding, ding. So, my
little alarm went off. When I hear, you
know, barely 20%, that's an indication
for me that there's probably an offer
issue on the back end, maybe even the
front end or a combination of the both
of how they work together. So, what's
the main problem? What's holding you
back? We need more better bees, right?
Yesterday. Yeah. Yeah. Long time ago.
Yeah. Yeah. Higher quality, higher
quantity, more more consistency because
it's like too too much variability,
lower cost, right? So, the lack of
consistency really feels awful. I don't
know what next month is going to be. Is
it going to be a good month or a bad
month? The good months are pretty good,
but I can't really fully enjoy them
because the bad months are so awful.
Because the way that we're doing sales
now is we will go for days, sometimes
weeks without any leads at all. And
finally, when we do get a lead, we'll
get them on the phone, we'll have the
calls, we'll pitch them, they'll get
excited, will get excited, and we get to
the end, we present the price, and deal
is dead. So, if you can imagine that
massive drought followed by a huge
disappointment, I'm really looking
forward to getting rid of that. A
$12,000 uh CAC is crazy, especially
considering the LTV. Ding, ding, ding.
Number two, we have a super expensive
cost to acquire a customer. And this is
a customer that should probably be 1,500
bucks, $2,500 bucks, maybe $3,500 to
acquire. So, there's definitely an offer
mismatch between what is being
advertised and what they're selling if
CAC is so high or they just have
atrocious sales processes. So, it's
either an offer, sales process issue, or
both. And we're going to figure it out.
What we've noticed that our our best
clients are existing restaurants, right?
And so we're considering refining our
targeting down to just serving
restaurants that are currently
operational making $4 million a year or
more in revenue. What could you sell for
like $8 to $10,000? Something that we've
tried in the past and could easily bring
it back is essentially a DIY like we'll
teach you how to do it. Mhm. The uptake
on that is what I would assume lower.
People have a hard time like doing
things if they're already not doing
things. I would think, is there a
different thing that could be sold that
was still in that price point that
wasn't DIY? I mean, basically, I
wouldn't position it as DIY. I would
just be like, we're not going to fly
out. The good news is I think this is
super fixable. Let's do the the quick
recap of all the numbers you got so far.
2024 revenue 1.1 million, profit
123,000, our CAC 11,800, very high LTV
to CAC of 1.7 to1. Our marketing spend
without salaries is $10,000 a month.
Close rate 66. So come here real quick.
Check this out. This is the $100 million
scaling road map. Ben is at stage four,
prioritize. And let me know if this
sounds familiar. He's saying yes to
anyone who would pay. He's got all these
different types of avatars. He's getting
way too many unqualified leads. But he's
getting people who are clicking. He's
getting people opting in, but they're
not the right types of people. Here's
his next problem. The result of all this
stuff is that he's got to specialize his
product. He's got to make better free
stuff and have better creative to boost
the volume and add qualifications and
friction. Sounding familiar? And so the
thing is is that as much as it always
feels like this unknown journey when
you're a business owner, businesses
behave in patterns. We broke out after
studying our portfolio companies, seeing
where they got stuck and how we broke
through and put into 10 stages. If
you're curious about where you're at,
this is absolutely free. Just go to
acquisition.com/roadmap, plug in your
business information and our automation
thingy will tell you what stage you're
at and what you need to do to get to the
next level. So, it's absolutely free. Go
check that out. And if you want our team
to like double checkck the work and make
sure that it's the right one and give
you more tactics around it, you can hop
on a call on the next page and we'd love
to help you out. The nice thing is that
like I feel very confident that your
business will will will grow because
there's some really obvious holes. I
think I honestly have what I need. Why
don't you come on this side and then
we'll probably we'll pow through it
together. Does that work? Yeah, that
sounds great. Uh, but before we get
started, would you mind if I uh made you
a cocktail? Ah, all right. I I'll be
saucy for our for our No, don't don't
worry, Alex. I took care of that. Uh, we
actually have a non grand slam offer
cocktail. Uh, which is really fantastic,
very refreshing, really great for making
sure that uh you we we both stay sharp
and focused
during the rest of our time together.
Um, but it's a delicious cocktail. As
you noticed, the grand slam offer. I
took a page out of your book, literally.
Consists of a few great ingredients that
are really going to help us stay like on
task. So, we have grapefruit juice,
fresh grapefruit juice. Squeezed it
myself this morning. A ginger mint
cordial to give it a little spice and a
little
herbaceiousness. And then we have our
pineapple
kombucha. I know way more people's
drinks than their actual names.
Grand Slam offered. Pam. Mind if I bring
it over? Yeah, by all means. Let's do
it. Thank you. All right. Here you go.
Oh, I get I got a full experience. There
we go. All right, man. Enjoy. Thank you.
Cheers. Cheers.
Oh, that's great. Awesome. I can
definitely see how the kombucha would
take off the edge of the of like it
could hide a a spirit really easily with
that. Oh, yeah. Okay. So, there's a lot
of things. So, I think that we need to
actually talk about the offer, which is
something that I don't always get the
opportunity to talk about, but I think
that you have a clear offer issue. I
think we need to talk about avatar.
That'll be as it relates to the offer.
Number three, and this is going to be a
big one, is going to be the funnel.
There's a lot of stuff that like a lot
of missing things there that I think we
can like really quickly fix. And then
sales. And then finally, maybe uh
ascension. And so that's kind of the big
the big overarching theme. Sure. So,
right off the bat, I think that you have
an offer issue. So, either that means
that we're getting the wrong avatars on
the phone or we're getting the right
avatars on the phone or we're offering
the wrong thing. Okay, so I would say
$30,000 is super expensive for just a
straight literally just a straight call
funnel. Very tough. So when Alex said I
had an offer problem,
I had a strong feeling he was right
because 4 and 1/2 years into the
business, if we're struggling the way
we're struggling, there's got to be
something broken. And if he Alex says
it's the offer, it's a good chance it's
the offer. for what you're looking at
CAC for a small business owner
restaurant I would imagine should
probably be in the neighborhood of
$1,500 $2,500. Okay, that's where that's
like if you were up at 3 $3500 be like
okay fine but it's going to be in that
kind of range. And so I think there's a
you can probably cut it by at least 2/3
compared to the you know 12,000 or
whatever that you're spending right now.
So I think there's there's a lot of
opportunity from that perspective. God,
there's there's so much stuff. Like, um,
I'm just trying to think, okay, why
don't we just start tip of the spear and
let's open up the ads, uh, since that's
the one that we can control the most.
So, right off the bat, we need to have
clear call outs. So, we need to be
talking about what avatar are we really
looking for. So, struggling to get the
most out of your cocktail program. I
don't know if that's necessarily even
the language that would matter. I also
wouldn't restate my name on one for
infiltrate hospitality because we
already have it above there. So, it's
like it's it's it's some of the most
valuable uh advertising real estate.
Yeah. And so I would probably have
something to the degree of like
restaurant owners asterric asterric, you
know what I mean? And then like second
line like is your like are you doing
over you know x million per year or it
could just be $4 million plus per year
uh restaurant owners is call out number
one. And then the question would be pain
based hook. All right. So check this
out. So I'm on page 136 of the leads
book. The first part I'm talking about
here is the call out. So we have to get
the right people to notice the ad and it
is by far the most important. And so I'm
trying to compress the things that he's
looking for in his ideal avatar into
just one line. So they're like, "Oh, I'm
a $4 million plus per year restaurant
owner or bar owner. Just put it there
and then like this is for me." And once
I do that, 80% of the work of
advertising is actually done. As crazy
as that sounds, what I'm getting into
further after that is, okay, let's see
if we can ask a yes question or an if
then statement uh or talk about some
ridiculous result. All of these things
are kind of the line after actually
calling out the prospect. Right? Now,
once we get a little further into the
copy, I like using the what, who, when
framework. So, this takes the uh value
equation, which I talk about in my first
book, this guy, and tries to like
explode this into many different copy
variations. And so, what we want to talk
about is both the dream stuff, which is
what's the good outcome, how do we make
it fast, how to make it likely, how to
make it easy, and then on the flip side,
the pain, which is what's your nightmare
scenario. And so this gives you a lot of
different angles to approach the copy
for a customer whether it's a BTOC
customer or a B2B business owner. And
the reason I'm such a big proponent of
pain in advertising is one is it's super
compliant. Two I have the belief that
the more precisely you can articulate
the pain of a prospect to that prospect
and
even describe it more accurately to
themselves than they can articulate it.
they will believe that you can help them
almost better than any promise that you
can make them. So, if you're like, "Hey,
did Sally say this yesterday? Did you
have this problem that showed up?" And
are you consistently running out of your
most expensive ingredients? But then
sometimes they go bad. All of a sudden,
like, God, this guy knows exactly where
I'm at and now I'm far more likely to
take the next step. Has cocktails been
less than 10% of your revenue
year-over-year? Something like that,
right? or cuz I know you said in the
messaging they they're not as receptive
to like profit money related stuff.
There are there are avatars that do like
profit but a lot of them like
recognition and being cool. Yeah. And
being cool, right? Yeah. They want to be
cool and they want to be like popular
like they want to be able to show off.
So people have different histories of
reinforcement, meaning they've had good
things that happened in the past from
different things that they've done. And
so if somebody did really well in
school, they like, you know, getting A's
and maybe the the score matters more for
them. Other people it's like they like
the applause. Other people it's like
they like showing up and having people
flock to them. Like everyone has
different drivers. We want to describe
what it's like the experience of success
in as many varied ways as possible to
attract the most varied avatars as long
as they meet our requisites. Like is
your cocktail program flaccid? Would
probably do great. Has no one ever
posted anything good about your your
cocktails in the last 2 years? If you
look at your reviews on Yelp, have do
you just have Long Island iced teas and
you know vodka sodas, right? Like you
might need a insert, you know, a bar
rehaul instead of saying cuz what this
is is super feature heavy data driven
menus designed to get more orders team
training that delivers because all that
sounds like work. Yeah. For me. Sure.
And so what I want is what occurs as a
result, right? And so I would be talking
more about like client C typically 10
10x their investment the first year, 30%
increase in menu orders. I'm not sure if
it like bites at me, you know what I
mean? And so it would be more like what
the experience is like from people just
ordering the things that they know off
the top of their mind to getting excited
when they open up your menu and then all
of a sudden saying oh man I want to try
so many of these and then ordering two
or three times more. So it's like dial
into the experience of what the avatar
is going to go through and then I would
translate it okay what about the
restaurant owner having you know your
restaurant featured in some of these
types of magazines which honestly
doesn't take as long as you think as
soon as you make these types of changes.
You know what a lot of restaurant owners
don't know is that one of the largest
profit drivers in the business is is
alcohol. And it's the one thing that
they're the least focused on. If you
want, you can book a call, but even if
you don't, what I did was I took the,
you know, the top 10 worst drinks to
serve, and I'll show you how to replace
them with the top with 10 drinks that
are better than that that work for just
about any bar. Now, on the thank you
page, so you can download that on the
next page, but on the thank you page, if
you want us to personalize it to your
bar concept, we'll show you uh how to
organize the bar so you can get way more
drinks served. you can do it with higher
margins and you don't have to train
people for nearly as long because if you
set it out the right way if that's
interesting book call next page right
and so that would be more or less my ad
right at least my ad structure and so
the the big thing number one is that a
is that we need better ads y so that's
going to be both the copy so we want
call outs to avatar we want to have pain
based hooks we want to be more benefit
versus feature driven B we want a
banging lead magnet what we want to do
ideally with a lead magnet is demonst
demonstrate authority and expertise with
something that they didn't know that
they should know, right? Cuz either you
reveal a problem, you give a sample of a
solution, or you give a one step of a
multi-step process. Those are the three
types of lead magnets you can give. So,
check this out real quick. So, this is a
perfect example of an offer and lead
magnet mismatch. So, kind of what I was
saying in the beginning, like we're
honing in here, and I'm pretty sure this
is the problem. So, what I explained
here, this is page 30 of the leads book.
He's trying to do this. He's trying to
go from low trust straight to a sale,
right? And in that scenario, he might
sell a couple people, which he is. But
instead, what I'm trying to get him to
do is put some sort of valuable lead
magnet first, which goes getting people
from low trust to high trust. And then
that increases the number of people be
more likely to buy from him after
demonstrating value. This is probably
the the like first big jump that we're
going to do in the business that I think
is going to have a huge impact on the
growth. And what I was referencing for
him is under lead magnets, uh, there's
always a continuous problem solution
cycle. And so the three types of lead
magnets are just like I named real
problem, have a free trial, or one step
of a multi-step process. It's almost
like I wrote the book on this Like
I think that's the right direction cuz I
think it being cocktail focused cuz
right now we've been working on a lead
magnet that's profit focused. Okay. And
it's straightforward. I mean essentially
it's a tool that they use in Excel and
they pull up a PMIX. They put in their
top 10 sellers. The quantity is the
price. Yeah. They make a 50 cent dollar
$2 adjustment and $50,000 in profit.
Yeah. Imagine, you know, that's great
for the profit driven avatar. Yeah. And
so I don't know if there's a way to like
kind of stack lead magnets. So I
wouldn't stack them. I would just test
one versus two. Got it. So, if we were
to just test 97 versus 47, you might
think, okay, well, maybe, you know, just
from the front end, $97 in the test that
we've run, actually, it converted almost
the exact same amount, but it was twice
the money. So, that was a good idea. But
where the real money was was the fact
that people who bought this were way
more likely to spend money. Now, for me
to answer why, no idea. Just know that.
And so, this is why we test all the way
through LTV, not just which one gets
more opt-ins or which one gets more
sales in terms of volume up front. What
you might find, though, is that maybe
the cost, and this is why it's important
to track all the way to the sale. Yeah.
And I'm going to show some more funnel
stuff. I'll show you how we need to
reorganize yours. But I would just run
that as an AV. So you're going to run
some ads. We're like, hey, so you'll do
the same exact intro. Y and then the
transition will be like, and if you want
the top 10 drinks that you shouldn't be
serving that actually hurt bars and
their profitability, download my thing,
and it'll show you 10 different ways of
making them that are more profitable and
faster. Got it. And then the other one
is like, and if you want to see how much
uh revenue you could potentially be
missing out on, I have a tool that we
use internally that I'll just give you
for free. You can plug in your numbers
and then it'll spit out exactly what the
opportunity is. And if you're like, you
know what, I'm not really a big Excel
guy. That's fine. On the SK on the thank
you page, schedule a call. We'll walk
you through it specific to your bar
right now. Right. Right. So, I think
both those work and I I would just split
test that. Like, I don't know the answer
to that question. they will, but lead
magnet for sure is one of the things
that's missing from these ads and also
probably why you're not getting the
conversion you need to on the um on the
on landing page. So, why don't you
click? So, we're going to swap this ad
out for an ad that talks about the lead
magnet, has a painbased hook, and kind
of mirrors some of the copy that I just
went through. Okay, go for
it. Okay, so right off the bat, that
like the the most expensive real estate
on this page is top to bottom, right?
And so, you having your logo at the top,
nix it, doesn't matter. No one knows who
you are yet. they're coming from cold
ads and like this isn't the branding
opportunity. Got it? So, yeah, this is
direct response. So, better bar program,
I would take that out because they don't
know what they're opting in for yet and
that doesn't mean anything. Launch an
elite high-profit bar. I would split
test the hell out of that. It might be
become the hottest bar in your town.
Okay. Just try out a few different Yeah.
No, 100%. And then beautiful cocktails,
professional team, and seamless
operations. I would nix that. So, I
would want the sub headline to be
basically the single largest concern
someone has about the promise of the
headline. Got it. So, here's this
amazing thing and here's that thing that
you're thinking about now that you don't
believe me and so let me tell you why
you should believe me in the next line,
right? Like the reason you're a cocktail
suck is because like yeah, I mean it
could be like with or the without,
right? So launch an elite high, you
know, high profit bar um without having
to redesign uh your existing location
without buying expensive ingredients
that go bad or having a really expensive
training process. Sure. I don't This is
just me thinking if I were a bartender.
So here there's a lot of pieces to this
and I don't think you need any of them
because I've already gone through your
funnel. I would basically drop this to
just I'll tell you why. So I'm okay with
all of these if it basically you collect
this information twice in this funnel. I
have you gone through it? I I built it.
Okay. So, let me So, let's go through
it. Let's just go, you know, aa just we
just put whatever in. Okay. a aol.com.
So, that was me. Yeah. Okay.
[Laughter]
My uh Yeah. My director of ops was
freaking out. She's like, "Is that you
guys?" She's like, "We got we got a
lead. We got a hot one." So, let's say
we click here now. Just click whatever
time. All right. So, now I got to put it
all in again, right? I'm like, "God,
this sucks." So, this is a really
classic business owner mistake, which is
that a lot of business owners haven't
even gone through their own sales
process. They set it up 2 years ago and
they haven't like gone through it. You
would be amazed at how many times you
change a couple things and then you go
through it again and you're like, "God,
this looks horrible." Except you're like
running traffic to it and this is what
customers are seeing and I like I'm
guilty of this too. So, I'm not saying
I'm immune to it. And so, having some
regular cadence of actually going
through clicking the buttons because
this is obviously a ton of friction and
this is bad friction. Good friction is
you add qualifications, you make sure
the right people are coming in, the bad
people are going out. But this friction
of just having people like repeat opting
in for stuff or like very slow load
times. That's bad friction that gets
both good and bad people to stop opting
in. So fundamentally, marketing comes
down to having the sweet spot on
friction. Because if I were to
advertise, hey, here's my phone number
and this is how much it is. Call me to
buy. That would have the least amount of
friction in the process possible. But
the issue is I'd probably get a ton of
people to call or maybe not. And it's
just like it's too fast. On the flip
side, if you make people jump through 30
hoops, you might have a perfectly
qualified customer, but you're missing
out on 90% of the people who would have
bought if you just made it a little bit
less frictiony. And so, it's all about
the sweet spot between both extremes.
And in general, the more expensive the
product or service, the more friction
you'll generally need to add. And so, my
little moniker for this is the bigger
the plane, the longer the runway in
order to get it to take off. Okay, so
now that we're we're back here, so first
off, this needs to not be on YouTube.
So, you need to get somebody because
otherwise it looks it looks hokey. Get
it on any third party. Get it on a
Vimeo, whatever. Yeah. You don't want
other recommend. It's just like it's
taking people off the site and I don't
think it looks good, right? Whatever.
This is what your new funnel look like.
So, you're going to have hopefully this
looks like a book. Yeah. Okay. Got it.
Okay. And then we have your email. We've
got our headline, sub headline. Mhm. And
then we've got our image. Right. So,
then that's then going to go here, which
you have uh congrats. And then we'll
have our main our secondary headline.
Now, here's where we put the video.
Okay? Above above theuler, okay? And
then the scheduleuler is going to be
here. So, this will be VSSL. Then
they'll have the booking and then
postbooking will have a separate thing
here which will one have the VSSL uh and
the lead magnet. So, it's just like that
way they can go to their email to get
it, but they also can click here to get
it. Just makes it convenient for them.
But what we have here though is
basically how to prepare for your call
and just more selling. Yeah, I'm a huge
advocate of having videos or kind of
sales materials prior to a human
intervention. And the reason for that is
if you've ever done sales on a
consistent basis, you end up kind of
repeating the same presentation, if you
will, over and over and over again. And
so then it starts to sound rehearsed.
The other person zones out, you zone out
because you've said it so many times. I
like taking all of the stuff that you
kind of repeat over and over again in a
sale and frontloading that. And so when
you're on the call or when you start the
call, you can start it like, okay, how's
everything sound? And now we can
basically start from the beginning to
making a decision rather than like just
like another pre-recorded, you know,
vomit of a salesperson. And the other
benefit of a video is that there's a lot
more visuals, right? Like if you're
talking on the phone, you're talking on
Zoom, you'll be limited in the amount of
visuals you can probably provide.
Whereas here, you might be able to
provide charts and graphs and statistics
and visuals that make it more compelling
and easier for somebody to understand. I
would rather have the perfect pitch
delivered every time in an automated
format and then one have the
customization be what the conversation
is after the fact to get them to decide
to buy or not. This is the new funnel,
right? And this is what we advertise.
And just real quick, this is after they
schedule VSSL. This is the VSSL again.
Just it's just a different one, but
yeah, it's a different one, but more
like prep for sales club. So, think
about like this. Think about all the
things that people present with on the
call early that are their biggest
concerns. Okay, that's what you put
there. Okay. So, you might be wondering
this, you might be wondering this. So,
let me let me put your minds at rest.
So, these are the things you need. You
don't need this. You do need this. If
you're concerned about these four
things, I'll break them down one at a
time. So, first things first, and then
walk through it, and I'll be on. So, you
know, have a computer. It's going to be
a Zoom caller. Expect it from this
number, whatever. So, call prep,
concerns, and this VSL. This one's like
more about like pain and promise. Okay.
Got it. Yeah. If we honestly like if we
just do this, you're probably going to
like significantly increase your sales.
Awesome. Um, and we do it like I mean
like we could probably do nothing else
today and like that's all that has to be
done, right? Is that the ads need to go
to the right avatar? Yep. Which is
called out. We're actually going to give
them a reason to go to this page that
they can immediately get value from.
They're going to opt in. Then we have
our Now, if you want to do more of the
uh you want to add more of the
information uh that you were collecting
over here, you can. That's fine with me.
As long as it's fully integrated Yep.
into here so that they don't have to do
it twice. If you want, you can put a
little on this side like in like a black
banner across the top of this that has,
you know, for $4 million plus only. Yep.
Got it. This is This is a big a big part
of this of what we were talking about
earlier. Sip my brain juice for a
second. Mhm.
I'm going to spill over. I got a lot of
stuff in
here. Okay. So, you're confident about
the $4 million avatar. Is there any
reason that two and $3 million avatars
don't work? They do. They just they're
going to be a harder sell because their
ROI isn't necessary. So then let's get
to the offer part because this this like
because this is this is the this is the
funnel and process. But now let's talk
about the offers that we're selling
here. All right. So let's put this cuz
now this is going to go to the phone.
This is a phone for everyone who was
born um before uh sorry after after
1995. So these are the offers. Okay. So
Ben has a clear offer problem. I wrote
my entire first book on this issue
because it's one of the most common
problems that limits businesses and the
offer is a strategic thing that you do
in that it affects the entire business.
If you change your offer, it changes the
advertising, it changes conversion
process, it changes your pricing, it
changes your deliverables. So, it
changes everything. But because of that,
if you nail the offer, that's where you
can have these massive upticks in growth
seemingly overnight. And so, I'll just
read this little piece for you. No
offer, no business, no life. Bad offer,
negative profit, no business, miserable
life. Decent offer, no profit,
stagnating business, stagnating life. I
would say he's right now between two and
three. Good offer, some profit, okay
business, okay life. And then what we
want to build is a grand slam offer,
fantastic profit, insane business, and
freedom. That's what we want to get to.
So, let's break this out. So, I think
that that offer straight off the bat,
selling $30,000 upfront, really tough
sale. Totally a very very hard sell. So
I like that he's charging premium prices
for premium services. That makes sense.
The problem is how he's selling it and
when he's selling it. The right offer at
the wrong time is still the wrong offer.
That's the problem he has. And so this
$30,000 thing absolutely should be and
maybe we need to change that. Maybe that
should be a 60 or $90,000 thing. But
selling it right off the bat is kind of
like he's getting people who've never
met him before to just get on a call and
then just try and buy. Rather than try
and go for that, I'd rather go for a
much easier sale that with that first
product or service, we can give them the
information so that now our entire
business is about upselling customers
into our 30, 60, $90,000 thing rather
than spending six phone calls to close
somebody on a $30,000 thing and having
people drop off at each of those steps.
This is how I if I owned your business,
Mhm. I would have my front-end thing be
like five or six grand. Okay? I would
have it solve one very specific problem
very well that more than, you know,
gives them a 50k ROI on a $5,000 thing.
But it's built in purposefully just to
get the quick sale transition from
prospect to customer. One call close,
not three call closes, which I'm sure
you're having to do right now just to
close, right? Yeah. You're arm wrestling
people to get 30 grand. We're missing
the point of even having this simple
salesunnel. And so get the 5K. Do the
three calls you were going to do as a
sale anyways. provide value for those
three and then at the end sell your 30K
thing. Got it? So, I think that the
changes that Alex recommended for the
funnel make a ton of sense. I'm not a
professional funnel designer. I've
really only been doing paid ads for the
last year. And listening to somebody
who's got as much vast experience like
Alex tell me exactly what I need to do
is super helpful. And I know that I
could probably figure it out over many,
many years and painful processes, but
ultimately having this path to create a
funnel that works is going to make me
feel a lot better. So, what can we split
off that's like five or six grand that
would be immediately valuable to them
that doesn't require a huge amount of
work, but they could just like they
could use your calculator, they could
make these changes and immediately see
like a return that would then create the
necessity for your main thing. Yeah, I
would say that the pricing is massive.
Okay. Another thing would be like just
very basic sales training for their
teams. Like they need they need a
script. Like they're bartenders and
servers. If you don't have a script for
your sales team, like you have no idea.
And the way you look at that is very
straightforward. How many drinks per
person are you selling, right? You know
number of guests, you know how many
drinks you're selling, you know, drinks
per guest. Yeah. Boom. That's like a
pretty easy metric to like kind of like
grasp onto. Which of those is easier for
you to deliver on? The pricing is like
massively easy because they just have to
change in their penis. Then I would then
I would I would go pricing audit first.
Yeah. Because also there's immediate
value in that. What I would do is like
let's b calculate how much more profit
you would have made last year if you had
these prices. Yeah. And then they're
like, "Holy I would have made 100
grand." And you're like, "Cool. So,
pretty good return on the five." Great.
If you like that, you're going to love
what I have for you next, which is how
do we actually make sure this happens
consistently quarter over quarter. This
is actually what we do with our, you
know, with our premier our premier
customers, right? It's too cold of a
sale right now. Yeah. So, either we have
to have a much longer sales process or
we lower the bar so we can just get them
in the door. Got it. And then we can
upsell. Right. and and the profit
booster, which is what we call it
internally, is like you think that that
is going to be meaty enough for them.
Obviously, it's 5K, right? We're not
selling 30. It's five, right? It's like,
dude, if we just fix this one thing on
more, then I know what your market looks
like. I like we have comps in the area.
We can tell you what this market can
sustain. And that way, the question is,
what's it worth to get it right on the
first shot? Mhm. So, like, for sure, I
could say, "Hey, just bump your prices
by 10%." But you probably freak out
about that. Of course you would, and
rightfully so. So, what we're going to
do is remix a couple of the things, get
the prices appropriate to your area that
we already know are working, so you
don't have to you don't have to sweat
about it, right? Done. So, it's like the
only real cost to you is reprinting your
menus, right? And then the next
step is like, do you want to raise your
prices again, but sooner? Well, you need
a better quality product, better trained
bartenders, etc. And I feel like that
could help them kind of understand that
they will have that opportunity to do it
again sooner because they already got
the bump. And the reason I want this one
is because this is fast and easy. Yeah.
Which I like selling those things first.
You have to do this in order to do this.
So, you might as well sell this first.
Okay. And the fact that it's easy and
fast and profitable like that checks all
the boxes for fast, easy, risk-f free.
There you go. Got it. Right. I think we
make this 5,800 on the phone for the
pricing booster, whatever you want to
call it. Yep. And then what we do is
that then leads to the quarterly
retainer at I think you had 9K per
quarter, right? And that's probably how
I'd price it. So, Alex's idea about the
$5,800 offer really makes a lot of sense
when he was explaining that trying to
sell somebody a $30,000 service cold
isn't working. There was a little bit of
an aha moment, but actually it's makes a
ton of sense. So, I'm excited to try to
find an opportunity to give our clients
or prospects that will become our
clients exceptional value right off the
bat. will one make it a lot easier to go
to the next step and also give us a lot
of quick wins so that we're not
constantly putting in all this work to
get nothing. Trying to think about the
easiest way to do this. I would probably
end up doing a rollover upsell. So,
we're selling step one of a multi-step
process. That's what this is. Yep. And I
would seed that up front. So, when you
sell the thing, it's like, listen, I'll
be real with you. My whole goal isn't to
give you this pricing audit. I'm just
going to easily ROI myself and like
everybody will be happy. What I really
want to do is help you really transform
the bar. Yeah, because you know you can
only do a pricing change once and then
after that what do you do right? But
even if we make this pricing change
great we made you an extra 100 grand but
wouldn't it be cool to make an extra
million? Now I'm not promising that
because obviously your results will vary
depends on your market but what I can do
is basically walk you through what it
takes to truly build this into a staple
that then also drives people into the
food side. So it becomes a a virtuous
cycle. And so what I want to do is take
your your your 5800 and I'll credit
towards the year. So if you're wondering
should every business have a backend and
a front end or multiple offers? The
answer is it depends. And I know that's
a terrible answer, but I'll tell you
what it depends on. There's a certain
amount of information that is required
for somebody to make a decision.
Depending on where they come in on that
continuum of needing a little bit of
information versus needing a lot of
information, then there has to be more
selling that must occur. Then the next
constraint that comes up in the business
is cash flow. Well, if we're spending
money to get these people in, we want to
recoup that cash as fast as we can. And
for somebody to buy maybe a $100,000
thing, it takes more time and more
information to make that decision. And
during that time, we're spending all
this money in labor and advertising, but
we're not seeing any return. The idea of
sometimes having a front end and backend
offer is mostly just to pull cash
forward, offset the the cash, the the
cash outlay, which is another way of
saying uh decrease the payback period or
increase the cash conversion cycle. Lots
of fancy words, but basically just get
money back faster. So that then
everything after that's all gravy. You
recoup the money. Now you go get another
customer. And then this person's all in
the incention process. for example, his
advertising was all brand-based and all
inbound, then he could probably get away
with just going straight to a more
expensive thing because they've already
consumed so much information prior to
that. But since he's almost entirely
based on cold traffic ads, we have to
lower the bar to get people to just take
that small jump so that he can then
prove himself to then take the big jump.
Got it. Seen that before. Yeah. Because
it works. Yeah. And so, and you do it,
but it's like you only get that if you
do that during the the two to four weeks
that we have, right? So that's the
that's the time window we can apply it
towards, right? And if you want, I'll
apply it to your first payment. So, you
know, the the 9K becomes 4K for your
first quarter and then you go into 9K
after that. Or if you want, one of my
personal favorites is just knock off
1,500 per quarter. So, make this 105 or
you know, 10K per quarter, but if you do
it now, it's 8,500. Got it? And we knock
it off that way. We we spread the
discount over four quarters. I gave Ben
two different ways of applying the
discount. I prefer spreading discounts
because I don't want an easy yes and
then go from 4K to 9K and then them say,
"Oh, actually, I'll just get the quarter
and then I'll cancel." I'd rather spread
the discount out and get the commitment
over the long term. And so, if someone's
willing to pay the 8,500, they're like,
"Okay, well, that was nice of him to
credit the the 5,800 or $6,000 towards
my payment." So, it's like a nice
gesture. It encourages people to take
action, but it's not so much so that
it's it's getting the wrong type of
customer in because the price is going
to double. That way, you're not, you
know, crushing your first your first
payment. Sure. and the 9K per quarter
which is what we're doing that is
continuity on the better cocktail
consulting thing. So how do we how
sticky is that? How sticky is it? How
how are people re upping the actual
design and implementation of their
cocktail menus or of this are people
turnurning out of this? Uh they yes like
basically anybody who buys it as part of
the initial package they don't continue
on with it like they stop after two
quarters. I have my suspicions on why
that's happening. Okay. Why? uh we are
not showing them the value. We're not
we're not demonstrating it in a
meaningful way. Like we're we're
supposed to fill out a scorec card.
We're supposed to show them week over
week how much better their program is
doing. We're not. You're not doing it.
Well, I have like Well, you have the
team. Sure. Yeah. So, there's a little
warning alarm that's going off for me
right now, which is that if people are
turning out in two quarters, basically
two payments, that's not a good sign.
You know, he nailed it. He's not
providing value. That's a kind of a mor
amorphous big term. But underneath of
that, it's like the question is why? One
of the difficult parts with uh
consulting or education is that if
you're what I would consider quote a
onetrick pony, I'm not saying Ben is,
but if you are, then once you kind of
like implemented your thing, it's like
why should someone keep paying you? So,
I like to figure out ways that we can
have some sort of consumables or
something that is always changing in the
business that is required for you to
keep providing value. One of the
benefits of a bar restaurant is that
they're always getting new staff in. And
so, new staff needs to get trained up
consistently. Now, the downside is if
they learn how you train, then they'll
just say, "Well, I'll just train them
myself and not pay you this money." We
have to figure out a way to make the
backend stickier or just accept that
it's not and then charge an appropriate
amount of money for it so that you
deliver that value, you have a good
margin, and you just understand that
that's the nature of the business. And
the good news is there's a gazillion
restaurants and bars, and so you'll be
able to do that for a very long time.
Well, some people try to create
recurring revenue for recurring revenue
sake, but some products and services are
not really meant to be recurring.
There's a reason that after four years
of of education in college, you
graduate. After high school, you move to
the next thing. Like education in
general tends to graduate people. They
learned and because they learned, they
no longer, you know, should continue.
Now, how does the education system uh
deal with this? They just give you more
and more majors and you can become a
master and you have a PhD and you can
become a double secret PhD, right?
They'll just always give you something
else. It's more common in like an
education and consulting business like
his, but the businesses that are most
valuable obviously are businesses that
once someone comes in, they never want
to leave or stop paying. But it doesn't
mean that you can't make a ton of money
in businesses that you do just one-time
services on. So, I don't think there's
anything wrong with that. There's just
less enterprise value. Why are they
doing it? I think there's a little bit
of resistance to just kind of numbers in
general from them. From them. I
co-designed that component of it for
them to do. Is there a way that you can
just get a login to their system and
then collect it? Definitely. I'll bet
you if you logged into their system and
once a month they had a meeting with you
where you showed them their numbers, it
would almost feel like I have like this
guy knows all my stuff. I have to you
know what I mean? And so I think that
would be worth the extra time cost.
Maybe it's 2 hours per per account or
whatever cares, right? That to me feels
worth improving cuz if you don't if if
you can't fix churn, there's no point in
doing any of this, right? Cuz otherwise
you just have people falling out the
back. It's like we have to start with
people staying and then we can fix all
the front end stuff cuz why would we
pour more to a leaky bucket, right? So,
how does this process feel? Overall,
feels great. I mean, it it's in line
with the direction I wanted to go in.
It's just obviously laid out much more
clearly and
using a system that that you know works.
Okay, good. As an entrepreneur, you try
to figure out a lot of things on your
own. You can do it a lot of ways. You
can do it by doing the research, trying
things out, or working with people who
have been there and done it before. with
Alex. Not only has he been there and
done it before, he's been there, done it
incredibly well multiple times for
businesses in tons of different
industries. And so when he says that
something's going to work, I believe it.
The sales training is like the
intermediary. Is that kind of what
you're recommending here? Because in my
head, the offer component starts with
the pricing part because that's the easy
win, right? that would then move into
the cocktail consult the better cocktail
the $30,000 offer and then that would
move into the 9,000 a quarter. Any
reason to not just push them into
continuity because they probably still
have shitty cocktails. I could make that
just I could just say we'll start we'll
just do our program and it'll just we'll
do it in the first three months. It'll
be the first quarter we'll be program
that's fine as long as we can maintain
the continuity. Yeah. There's an offer
structure that I like a lot called the
wave fee offer. So basically, I could
say, "Listen, this thing I charge
$30,000 for." Yep. If you commit for the
year, y I'll wave it. Yep. But you're
committing for it now. If you want to
cancel two quarters in, you have to pay
me this. Yep. Got it. So it's like I'll
eat the If I take the risk on, you make
the commitment. That's the risk you
take. Yep. And I'll front you all this
work. Mhm. If you take the risk, so you
want to have the you don't want the
commitment, then pay for that. I'll do
it. And then it's month, it's quarter to
quarter. Yep. Which one would you
prefer? Got it. But now it's an AB
close, right? That help? Yep.
Absolutely. Okay. I'm going to talk
about ascension in a second, but I think
I think big picture, we have funnel
redo. Yep. So, we got that going. Mhm.
Number two is ad call outs. Three is we
have new lead magnet. Four, we have So,
inside of funnel redo, we have
three-step and then Vimeo video above.
Yeah.
And then we have
integrateuler with optin. All right,
let's pull this page up again real
quick. So, I'm going to design this as
though it were the second page cuz the
first page is really simple. It's just
headline, sub headline, image, optin.
That's it. Got it? All right. So,
basically the first half here you could
peel off and make that the first page,
but you'll have a picture of the thing
that you're you're going for, right? And
you're going to remove the the top two,
you know, you remove your logo, you're
going to remove better bar program, take
that out. Beautiful cocktails is going
to be the uh without X Y and Z that
you're confir you you know your your
biggest concerns. Now let's scroll down.
All right. Cocktails that capture highly
trained bar teams functional product. I
would think about it like this like
create drinks that create regulars. Get
staff that customers can't wait to come
back to. And tip like crazy, you know,
parenthesis. Sure. And then functional
operating processes. That's like all
about headache reduction. Yeah. I want
to think like functional operating
processes. is the way to the way what I
think about when I'm writing copy. Yeah.
Is what are the moments? So if I have
functional like operating process,
what's the moment for me as a restaurant
owner or a bar owner that I would
experience the benefit of functional
operating processes? Is it when I
realized that I didn't have to throw out
all this inventory that I like all these
old pineapples that I thought I was
going to need and then toss out? Like
like what's the moment or moments? It's
a it's kind of one of those things like
when you notice the pain isn't there
anymore, right? Like that's a hard thing
to kind of put your finger. Well, then
tell me what the pain is. Pain works
fine. Like like the pain that they
typically have with dysfunctional
operating process. Give me a moment. Is
like when they walk in, the bar is a
total mess cuz no one knows how to set
it up. Like no more disaster back bar
back or back of bar. Mhm. Boom. Like it
just like you can you can do the
negative or the the the relief of the
positive. Okay. Now let's scroll up.
Okay. Unlock consistent proven results.
I would say like we drive quarter over
quarter alcohol sales growth cuz that's
what it that's what to me proven results
doesn't mean anything as a word. Mhm.
30% cocktail sales, 40% return of
beverage, 50% speed of service. I would
actually use the numbers as the subtext
and I would use the benefit as the
primary text. Okay, so speed of service
is like get rid of waiting lines and
then it says underneath 50% boost in
speed of service. That's me personally.
So I referenced earlier in the ads
around the copy, but now we're applying
the same frameworks from who, what, when
to the landing page. I like to speak in
terms of moments because people don't
really like they have to translate or
unpack a word of like a process or some
specific improvement. It just takes
mental effort and every piece of mental
effort you ask someone to use a certain
percentage of people say, "Nah, I've got
other things in my life." And they'll
dip. I want to predigest the food. I
want to predigest the pain and explain
the moments that they probably recently
experienced that will then make them
believe that I have complete context on
their problem and therefore are high
likely to be able to solve it. So,
there's a number of really small things
that you can do at a page that can have
a really big improvement. First off,
like everything that someone sees above
the fold, like that's the most important
part of the page. Like what happens on
someone's mobile device or their desktop
before they scroll, that's above the
fold is kind of what they say in the
marketing world. If you've got like the
name of your business and it's cold
traffic, they don't know, they don't
care. So, like take that out because
they don't know who you are. And so,
then the headline itself, it's like we
want it to be some sort of very clear
like reason for them to move forward.
And then I usually have sub headlines
that clarify or add context to the
headline. And so often times that'll be
like without X, Y, and Z or without
pain. It qualifies it. Underneath that
it's like I want it to be as simple and
clear as possible what they're going to
get. And then basically everything below
the fold is just if you're still
skeptical, let me just give you more
information to make the decision. But I
want all of the information I'm
providing to be relevant to why someone
should move forward, not just like a
whole bunch of stuff about us. And then
make sure that you have disclosures
around around results to make sure you
explain how these things are calculated
and otherwise it could just be an
unsubstantiated claim. So, lead mag. So,
we have the new lead magnet. Uh, we have
the new funnel. We have the new ad
callouts. This is great. We're going to
have the
$5,800 pricing offer, which I like. And
then ascension. Okay. Which is going to
be rollover. I think there's a C in
there somewhere. No. Ascension via
rollover plus waved 30k offer. All
right. Also, the thing is is this this
in-person onboarding is going to serve
as such a good like first experience for
them because you're going to fly out,
you're fix, like, "Wow, this was so
worth it." And right now, your team does
all of this stuff, right? Not you. I'm
all acquisition. Okay. You're But the
people flying out is your team. Yeah.
Exactly. Yeah. No, I never I I stay at
home. So, what I want to do Yeah. Yeah.
So, what I want to do is add an ultra
high ticket with you. Yeah. So, just 5x
the price. Yeah. And you can uh present
that first leader or the get the gas and
be like or I can have my team do it.
It's me the exact same process. It's
just I got I got a wife and kids and so
you want me out there I'll do it. Happy
to. And it's just obviously you know
this is what we do but they're going to
run the same flip. Got it. So
effectively the $5,800 pricing is part
of like an extended sales off% instead
of taking three calls or four calls like
you are right now. Just get paid deliver
the value and then once you have an
exchange they get more than what what
it's worth. Customers versus prospects
are like 10 times more likely to buy
again, of course. And so just get them,
make them customers so you can increase
the likelihood. So then they buy again,
right? Like give them a ton of value.
Have it all be with me. And it's easy
cuz this is just pricing related, right?
It's pricing third, you know, 15 30-day
fix. They immediately see the value.
You're like, dude, if you like this,
you're going to love that, right? Do you
feel like there's a t like a lot of
value from me doing all that fulfillment
or do you think that that's something
that I can also have somebody on my
team? I think you do it first to get a
feel for it. Sure. Totally. that. And uh
and cuz what I want to make sure that we
nail is this. Got it. Cuz we're not in
it for the $5,800 thing, right? We're in
it because we want to see I would want
to see at least 50% upgrading into that.
Yep. Okay. Get that get to here and then
make them the money to pay you the next
thing. And I would say the way that I
operate is that I never want to ask you
for money I haven't already made you.
Got it. And you'll notice that's a
common theme of how I roll. And so it's
like let me go make you a h 100red
grand. We make you that with the the new
bar program, right? And then with the
next thing, it's going to cost you a
third of what I already made you, right?
So, you're good. I've already made room
for you to afford me, right?
Essentially, it's much easier sale,
right? So, I charge them $5,800. They're
now making $9,000 a month, month over
month, and they're like, "Oh, look, you
have $90,000 that you didn't have
before. Look, you can use that on us."
Right? Got it. And you want to make sure
that you make that offer before the end
of that 30-day period. Totally. So, it's
like you want to offer it at week two,
three, again at four if you need to. And
it the way that I offer those things is
either I'll do immediate upsells if I
don't have that, which in this one it
doesn't make sense. So you'd have the
milestone moment. So they implement it
and they have their first weekend after
the pricing audit and their sales are
the same or their sales go up and
they're like, "Holy I made way
more money." So that would be a moment
that I would immediately ask for the
sale. The next one um that I would have
is basically like the next week cuz this
is a pretty short time. And then finally
you have last chance. So you have three
shots at the sale for this. Now you were
taking sales calls before. Yeah. But now
you're talking to a customer. Yeah. And
they've already delivered them value,
right? Easier. And they're making money.
Exactly. Okay. I mean, big picture, if
we're looking at this, like the funnel
redo on its own could very well triple
the lead volume that you're getting
right now. Okay. Honestly, just the
combination of the funnel redo, the ad
call out, and having a lead magnet that
actually resonates with that specific
avatar, like this alone could probably
just triple. Mhm. Just these things.
Mhm. This is going to dramatically
improve sales velocity. Sure. Let's talk
about sales real quick. What do you do?
Like so what's the walk me through what
like how you structure the conversation
for sales. You already have something.
Yeah. So that's the that this is the
like the click to close, right? Prospect
the ad, they visit the landing page.
Soon to be optimized. Yeah. Fill out the
form. Yeah. Yeah. Fill out the form and
that automates a text message. Text
message and email flow. So text message
and email. This I guess if they didn't
book. Yeah. It'll still it'll still go
out. They'll have the for the link to
book, etc. It also triggers a call for
my director of ops who's largely
involved in the uh the intake process.
So she conducts an intake. This was
previously for the we had this intake
process in place because of lowquality
leads. So she would take an intake call
uh 15 minutes. If they were qualified,
she sent them off to me. I'd conduct a
discovery usually about 30 minutes. I
talk to them about what their biggest
pain points are. I ask them all the
different questions about what they want
to see. What percentage of them have
been watching the video? This new video?
No. What percentage of them have been
watching the video after like when they
get on the phone with you? Oh, that that
video is new. Okay. Yeah. So, that's
like month. Got it. Yeah. Well, this
last month you've taken sales calls.
Have any of them mentioned the video?
No. Okay. So, they're not watching it.
So, this the way that I structured it
here where they're going to have to see
the video before they Well, they'll see
it and they'll have to scroll in order
to get to theuler will probably increase
the likelihood they they actually watch
it. But the other thing is is that that
set call. Yep. So, I'm going to make
this number seven. set goes to then
video. Yep. To then close. So, your
director of ops is going to say,
"Awesome. So, uh I'm going to set you up
with Ben, but before you get on, I'm
going to send you this video. Make sure
you watch it and I'm just going to say
do that cuz the first question he's
going to ask you is, did you watch the
video?" So, and if you have it, he's
just going to say, "Okay, I'm going to
grab a coffee. Can you watch the video?"
So, you're going to do it either way, so
you might as well just do it now. And
so, and also for you when you hop on the
call, I'll be like, "Did you watch the
video?" If they say no, it's like,
"Great, watch that." And I'd be like,
and the reason we do that is because I
already have a lot of facts and figures
and things like that that I could
describe with my words, but it'll take
us three times as long as you just
watching it. And so then that'll give us
good context rather than me just spewing
stuff at you, which most people are
like, "Okay, fair enough." But you don't
want me to just give you a lecture for
10 minutes. I don't want to either. This
has some graphs. It has some figures in
it. That makes it a little bit more more
digestible for you. Totally. And so
yeah, that'll be the sales process
there. Mhm. Proposed call. And you'll be
like, honestly, if you do these things
at this price point, I think you'll be
able to start closing like at that point
a lot. Yeah. Yeah, cuz if we if you were
closing like 50% which I think you could
if you're an owner operator and you're
at this point after this kind of process
you'll you'll I mean I think you could
some some people owner operator close
like 80% on these calls. So I'm a big
believer in founders selling the product
in the beginning and I think there's a
number of reasons for that. One is it
keeps you close to the customer. You can
understand how the marketing is doing.
You can see who's coming in and that
will give you a very rapid feedback loop
in terms of what you need to adjust on
the front end and how you can kind of
get feedback on your offer and your
pricing. And it takes out one very
important variable, which is that if you
have a salesperson who's in there, you
might not know if they're doing a good
job. So you might be like, "Ah, they're
not closing. What's the problem?" And
they might be like, "I don't know. These
leads suck." But like, is it a pricing
issue? Is it a copy issue? Is it an
avatar issue? Being closer to it, you
would be like, "Oh, no. Is this these
are the these are the right people that
we're talking to and they're just
shocked at the price or they're not
shocked at the price, but they're just
not getting it." And so each of those
would kind of offshoot into different
types of solutions. The big thing is
though, I like founder selling in the
beginning as well because when you're
the founder, you're the most convicted.
And so you will typically be able to
outperform any salesperson and in the
beginning when you have fewer resources,
you could use the extra conversion
percentage and the decreased cost of not
having a salesperson or paying the
commission. So think I can close twice
as many sales and I don't have to pay
the commissions for it. It frees up cash
flow so that we can make some of these
big bets early on that are going to
build the foundation for the business.
There's so few leads that are coming in
that I think he should be taking these
calls. Basically, until he can't take
these calls anymore. And by the time he
can't take these calls anymore, he's
already completely blown past his
revenue level. He'll have a whole bunch
more revenue and cash flow to then solve
the problem of him not having time. And
that's the game of business. With that
being said, that would be like if you
just did that, it would be more than a
5x in sales. Mhm. Because if you'd get
to 30% close rate would mean that you'd
make the same revenue, right? without
your actual $30,000 back end, right? But
if you're at 50%, you're making 40% more
revenue and then you still have your
back end, right? One last thing is that
I understand why you're not spending
that much money, but you were spending
too little money. With the fixes that
we're at now, it it would be okay to
keep the spend that you have, but if I
were selling a $30,000 thing, you're
barely sell you're barely advertising
enough to get enough volume for
something of that ticket. And so for me,
if I test stuff, I usually test at two
times CAC per campaign. Yep. So, sorry.
Two time. Yeah. Two times allowable CAC,
not current CA. Yeah. Yeah. Right.
Exactly. Um, that's kind of my benchmark
per campaign, though. So, I might run
multiple campaigns to figure out which
one's working. But for you, your your
funnel process was messed up and that's
why this is that's why your your numbers
aren't good. Yeah. Got it. So, what I'm
referencing here is that I budget two
times the cash I collect from the from a
customer in 30 days when I'm testing new
ads. For example, if I make $100 in
profit from a customer in the first 30
days, I will let an ad go to $200 in
spend before shutting it off as long as
I'm getting leads. And the reason for
that is usually because there's a
certain amount of inefficiency in the
beginning that you have to be willing to
stomach to find the ads, the copy, the
hooks, the creative variations that are
going to ultimately perform. I have to
be able to stomach bad ads that don't
convert and make up for it in good ads
that do convert and then be like, "Okay,
so this is working not as efficiently as
I want, but it's working. Now, let's
double down on this and make 10 more
variations that are more similar to this
messaging." Yeah. And once he finds the
messaging that converts, it's like by
all means blow the doors off and you
know spend as much as you can or at
least as much as you can while being
able to take all the sales calls. That's
it. Like this really fixes this. The
good thing is like this like you wanted
to hit your triple. I make no
guarantees. These are high likely like
shots. Okay. That's very encouraging.
Yeah. No, you've got it. And I think
this is the key cuz also think about all
the calls you're not going to have to
take. All the ones that are three calls
and then don't close. Right. Right.
You're spending all your time on these
wasted calls when it could be one call
closing 5,800 5800 5800. And so you see
this as a one call close at 5,800 like
discovery for sure. Discovery like oh
that's your problem. Yeah, I figured for
sure like here's here's the solution
right here. Not even a question. Yeah,
got it. That's like there you should be
expecting one and you should set that as
the agenda. You'll say your you know the
four things you have to say legally. Hey
this is X call from Y in regards to Z.
You know by the way this call is
recorded. Before we get going um just
want to say you know how you doing
today? Great. Uh let me set the agenda.
I'm going to go through the lead magnet
thing that you just got. I'm gonna
understand some of the metrics about
your about your bar and then at the end
um if it's a good fit, I can explain to
you um how we might be able to help you
out. Sound good? Great. And then we just
go through. I almost forgot cuz Michael
wants me to do this. Oh yeah, we could
this could be this could be I mean it
actually could be your triple could be
right here. Um you could definitely two
to 3x your call outs uh in terms of CTRs
with the ad call out. I'll bet you your
conversion rate. Do you know what your
conversion on your on your landing page
is right now? Like last year it was like
7%. Okay. So, so 7% could probably go
closer to 30% which is my benchmark for
a lead mag landing page which should be
like a nice little chill 4x here. I
think you going from 6% close rate to
like 30 to 50% is super reasonable given
the fact that you were the one who's
going to be selling it and the price
point is what it is. So I think in a
real way you might even make more money
just selling this than you're currently
doing with none of the extra work and
then all of this. God bless. This right
here is just going to be gravy. Yeah.
So, you're basically going to be able to
stack potentially probably a double of
your current revenue from this source,
but then stack 100% of your current
revenue from this. How do you like this
plan? Love it. It's a lot of what I want
to do. Oh, good. And it's I've started
kind of trying to figure out if this is
something that makes sense for me to do
and then obviously seeing it all on
paper and coming from you gives me a lot
more confidence to want to do it. I
would do it pretty much in this order.
You're going to redo the funnel. Yep.
Once the funnel's redone, technically
the lead mag would happen at the same
time as the funnel. So one and three
happen together. Yeah. Ad call outs, you
then run the ads. This is basically your
phone process. So this happens up front.
Four and six would happen together cuz
this is sales process. Yep. The
ascension happens after they buy. This
is also going to happen again with sales
process. So basically one and three
together, two happens next. Four, six,
seven happen third. Then you go back to
your ads guys and say, "Hey, go spend
more. Go find more keywords." Say it's a
grand slam offer. There we go. Hold on.
Let me let me
It's all about the picking.
Cool. Cool. All right. Awesome. I was
both very excited and very nervous to
come into something like this to really
put it all out there and be vulnerable,
not just in front of somebody who I have
an immense amount of respect for, but
also people who are going to watch this
video. You guys, that was awesome
getting through that, right? And I felt
once it was actually done felt amazing,
right? Like it felt great to know that I
have a path forward that I can really
count on. And while I know that no
guarantees are there, I do know that I
feel a lot better and that's important.
So I really liked Ben's business is
clearly he understands the the bar
business well, which is one of my big
requisites, like actually be good at the
thing before trying to sell the thing. I
think if he makes some of the changes
that I outlined, it's very likely that
the business does well. And I like to be
clear. This is in no way a promise that
you who's watching this is home. If you
do this in your business that you'll get
the same results because his results are
completely up to him and the effort that
he takes and his background and his
knowledge. So your results may vary.
That being said, if you enjoy this type
of stuff, these business breakdowns,
these cash guys episode, you'll
definitely want to check out this